تجددت الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في انحاء عده من
الخرطوم يوم الاحد في خلق جديد للهدنه
التي تعتبر ثالثه منذ بدايه النزاع والتي
تبادل الجانبان الاتهامات بخرقها عده مرات
ياتي هذا بالتوازي مع تسارع عمليات اجلاء
الاجانب من السودان وتحذير قوى سودانيه من
ان تكون الخطوه مقدمه لتوسع الصراع في
الفتره المقبله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا اولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله التعثر
المستمر في الهدن الانسانيه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع وما احتمالات التواصل الى
مثل هذه الهدن والالتزام بها بعد اجراء
الاجانب من السودان وما الخيارات المتاحه
امام طرفي النزاع المسلح في السودان في
ضوء انعدام الثقه الراهن بينهما وغياب اي
مبادرات جاده لوقف اطلاق النار في البلاد
وما السيناريوهات التي يمكن ان تؤول اليها
الاوضاع في السودان اذا استمرت المواجهه
المسلحه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
خروق جديده للهدنه الثالثه في السودان
تلحقها بسابقتيها من حيث عدم احترام
الاطراف لها وعدم تمكن المدنيين منها
تجددت الاشتباكات وان بصوره متقطعه في عدد
من مناطق الخرطوم بينها محيط القصر
الرئاسي وسط العاصمه واحياء مبدا في ام
درمان غرب الخرطوم بيداء ان الهدوء الحذر
الذي نعمت به الخرطوم منتصف نهار الاحد
شهد نشاطا ملحوظا لحركه اجلاء البعثات
الاجنبيه برا وجوا بالتزامن مع تسارع
وتيره هذه العمليات وتركيز الاهتمام
الدولي على تنفيذها وغياب اي مبادره جديه
لانهاء القتال
طرفات صراع في السودان استمر في تبادل
الاتهامات بخرق الهدنه كما فعل في
الهدنتين السابقتين فقد قال الدعم السريع
ان الجيش خرق الهدنه المعلنه وقصف
بالطائرات قواته في منطقه كافوري بالخرطوم
بحري ودانت قوات الدعم السريع هذا القصف
الذي قالت انه يتنافى مع الالتزام المعلن
بالهدنه المعلنه مساء الجمعه لمده اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه
الجيش من جانبه تم الدعم السريع بخرق
الهدنه وتوعد بانهاء وجوده في العاصمه
خلال يومين
الهدنه ما بدات لذلك ما في ودنه
وعرفوا بالجبن وعرفوا بالاعتداء لا دين
ولا اخلاق اليوم
في اجنده بتاعته خارجيه الان الدول
الخارجيه تراجع قالوا دين منظمه ارهابيه
او دي مجموعه بتاع العصابه الحراميه الناس
فيما تبقى من يوم يومين ان شاء الله نعلم
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من عمان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
وننتظر ان ينضم الينا من الخرطوم كل منا
سيد عزمي عبد الرزاق الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي والجميل الفاضل الصحفي والمحلل
السياسيه لواء فايز مرحبا بك معنا تواليب
اذا لواء فايزه دويري مع توالي هذه الهدن
وتوالي خروقات هذه الهدن حتى وان كانت في
محل عمليه اجلاء للبعثات الاجنبيه وهو ما
يهم طرفي القتال في السودان ما امكانيه ان
تطبق هذه الهدن على الارض
يعني في ظل المعطيات الحاليه بعد متابعه
لتسعه ايام من القتال وتصريحات قادت
الجماعتين سواء الجيش او الرد السريع نجد
ان الازمه تسير فيما يطلق عليه حافه
الهاويه
ولان كلا الجانبين تسريحات البرهان او
حميدتي او اركان القياده هنا وهناك جميعها
تدخل في مباراه صفريه
وجميعها تصر على الغاء الاخر والقضاء عليه
والاستمرار في هذا الاتجاه
لن يكون لدى اي منهما في المنظور القريب
او الاطار الزمني القريب القدره على الحسم
وتحقيق الغايه هذا سيدفع باتجاه توسيع
دائره الازمه ودخول اطراف جديده الى
الصراع سواء بمرجعيه مسلحه والسودان مليء
بالجماعات المسلحه الصغيره والكبيره او
الجماعات السياسيه وقد تطالبعد العرقي
والقبلي والسودان يتميز ببعد عرقي وقبائل
متناحره في معظم الولايات وبالتالي هذا
يعني الدخول في الفوضى العامه والاقتتال
الاهلي الذي قد يفضي الى عمليات النزوح
والتهجير القسري وغير ذلك لكن
لا امكانيه في الذهاب الى تحقيق هدنه
حقيقيه اخرى على علات الهدى الاخرى
بالخروقات الحاصله فيها
لو سمحت فقط في عجاله اكمل لانه ليس كل
الصوره قاتمه يعني الان هذا هو السيناريو
الاسوا او ما يطلق عليه المعادله الصفريه
او حافه الهاويه لكن بعد استمرار القتال
لفتره تاخذ اسابيع وتضعف القدره القتاليه
والاقتصاديه لدى طرفي الصراع قد
يعود الى الرشد والعقلانيه ويدرك ان هذه
معادله خاسر خاسر وليس معادله صفريه وهنا
يتم التوجه باتجاه ما يطلق عليه السيناريو
الاثيوبي اثيوبيا المركزيه لمده عامين
ولكنها انتهت في بريتوريا بعدما وصلوا الى
قناعه انه لا منتصر في هذه الحرب
الاحتمال الثالث الاحتمال الثالث
السيناريو الليبي ان ينتصر الجيش ويستعيد
المازق بالجمود المؤلم لكلا الطرفين
عسكريا على الارض هو امر قريب
يعني تقريبا هو افضل الحلول المتوقعه جميع
الخيارات سيئه بسبب المواقف السياسيه
لنذهب الى المقابلات التي اجراها البرهان
او حمدتي مع الجزيره او مع العربيه او
غيرها وبالتالي هؤلاء هم اصحاب القرار
وناخذ قراءه معمقه لما تحدثوا به نجد ان
كلاهما كلاهما يكن الخصومه والعداء
والرغبه في القضاء على الاخر
والكبرياء الداخليه بانه يستطيع حمدتي
يقول انتهاء الحرب بتقديم البرهان كمجرم
حرب
والبرهان يقول على حمدتي بمعنى ان يعرف
حجمه ويخلي الخرطوم اذا دعيني اقول كلاهما
صراع الجنرالات هذا متى يمكن ان يصلوا الى
نقطه توازن ويدرك كل منهم قدراته الحقيقيه
وانه لا يستطيع اقصاء او القضاء على الاخر
هنا يمكن ان يجلسوا الى طاوله الحوار
واشرت الى المقاربه الاثيوبيه مع اقليم
تقراي عندما ذهبوا الى بريتوريا وتم
الاتفاق لانهاء الخلافه والصراع هذا هو
تقريبا المخرج الذي
يجمع شتم الدوله السودانيه يجري الذهاب
الى مثل
هذا النوع او هذا السيناريو كما ترى لواء
فايز مع حاله انعدام الثقه وغياب الاراده
للطرفين وتحدثت عن تصريحات البرهان وحميتي
التي تدعو يعني الى اثناء الاخر
هذا متى بعد ان يستمر القتال لفتره لفتره
معينه تضعف القدره القتاليه تضعف القدره
الاقتصاديه اتمنى ان لا يكون هناك تدخل
اقليمي بتزويد السلاح او بتزويد بالمقدرات
هنا يشعر كل طرف ان قدراته القتال
القتاليه بدات تتلاشى هناك قد يكون حراك
شعبي هناك حراك من فصائل مسلحه قد تذهب
باتجاه التجزئه والتشرذم والانفصال هنا
يبصر الحقيقه هنا يبصر الحقيقه انه غير
قادر على تحقيق ما يصبو له وعليه ان يقدم
تنازلات وهذه التنازلات تقابلها تنازلات
من الطرف الاخر لانه سيعاني كما يعاني
الطرف الاول هنا يكون اللقاء وهنا يكون
الضغط الدولي والاقليمي والدول الفاعله ان
تجمع ان تجمعهما على طاوله معينه من اجل
انهاء وحسم هذه المشكله والا على السودان
سيذهب بطريقه تجزئه خاصه ان بدايات تجزئه
السودان بدات من ستينيات القرن الماضي حتى
ساعود لموضوع
عندما خرجت وهو موضوع خلق الهدى وهذه
الهدنه اساسا كانت هي الثالثه خصوصا هي من
اجل اجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه والاجانب
برايك يعني
كيف سيقرا الشعب السوداني المواطن
السوداني هذا الحرص من كلا الطرفين على
يعني
التلويح بانه هو الاكثر حفاظا على هذه
الهدنه وانه كان يحاول توفير الحمايه لهذه
البعثات في عمليه خروجها في الوقت الذي
يعني يستقبل فيه المواطن السوداني القذائف
من قبل الطرفين
يعني اترجم الحرفيه البسيطه ان هذه الهدن
هي كما قيل كتاب غلافه جميل ولكن مضمون
سيء
هذه الهدى هي والاصرار عليها كما اشرت هي
رساله الى الخارج ورساله بان هذا الجانب
يسعى الى السلام هذا الجانب حريص على حياه
المواطنين للاجانب هذا الجانب يمكن
التعاون معه وبناء شراكه مستقبليه ولكن
دعيني اشير الشعب السوداني الذكي والمواطن
العربي ذكي جميعنا يعلم ان هذا هو رضوق
وليس عمليه قبول باريحيه ودعيني اشير الى
نقطه تحدث حمدتي وقال تم التواصل مع قائد
الافرو كم وتم التنسيق حول اجلاع
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين ماذا كان جواب
البنتاجون كان رفض قاطع لما ادنى به الحمد
قالوا لم يتم التنسيق لم يتم تم توجيه
تعليمات وارشادات بانه يمنع عليك ان تطلق
طلقه يمنع ان تتخذ اي اجراء والا فالعقاب
شديد فبالتالي هذه الموافقه سواء من
البرهان او حمدتي والحرص على انجاح
الاجلاء هو ليس احتراما للادميه بقدر ما
هو خوف من العقاب فيما لو حدث شيء للبعث
الامريكيه او البريطانيه او غيرها من
الدول الفاعله وبالتالي هنا يصل الشعب
السوداني الى قناعه ان هناك دم ازرق يجب
ان يتم الحفاظ عليه وهناك دم مستباح لا
يقدر للاسف هذه هي المعادله قد تكون
قراءتي سوداويه ولكن من خلال متابعاتي هذا
ما قراته ولكن لنقرا اكثر اكثر لواء فايز
بمعطى خروج هذه البعثات الدبلوماسيه
للدول وحتى بعثه الامم المتحده وحتى
التلكؤ حتى من
الاجسام الافريقيه الايجاد وال اتحاد
الافريقي ايضا في عمليه الارسال
للوسطاء الى اي درجه ترسل رسائل بالتخلي
وترك عن السودانيين في والمشهد السوداني
والعمليه السياسيه السودانيه في هذا الوقت
يعني نعم اتفق معك في في هذا الطرح بانها
رسائل سوداويه الى الشعب السوداني الى
الشعب السوداني ان الجميع تخلى عنه ولكن
هي
بالمقابل هي قراءه استشرافيه للمالات
كافه السفارات خاصه سفرات الدول الغربيه
امريكا بريطانيا فرنسا وحتى روسيا الدول
الفاعل والنافذه وذات التاريخ في التواجد
مثل فرنسا وبلجيكا وهولندا كافه هذه
البعثات وهذا ليس سرا يوجد بها عناصر
استخبارات
واجبهم جمع المعلومات وتقديم نصائح الى
اصانعي القرار وبالتالي كانني اقرا فيما
كتبوه وان لم اطلع عليه ان هذا التقييم
يمكن وضعه بثلاث كلمات
الماساه والمشكله تتوسع تتعمق تتعقد
تتوسع تتعمق تتعقد وبالتالي عليكم اخراج
رعاياكم الدبلوماسيين ومن ثم المدنيين
الذين يعملون بالقطاع الخاص وغير ذلك قبل
ان تضيق الدائره وتنفلت الامور ولا تستطيع
اخراجهم اذا وقعوا الرؤيه ما الذي تتوقعه
هنا لواء فايزه دويري مع خروج البعثات
واتمام عمليه الاخراج لهذه البعث والعوائل
وحتى الذهاب الى اخراج الرعايه ما سيناريو
اليوم التالي
هو
كما قلت تتوسع تتعمق تتعقد وبالتالي دائره
الصراع ستشتد دائره الغلو في القصف
واستهداف مواقع الاخرين وان كانت ضمن
الاحياء المدنيه ستزداد سنشهد ضراوه في
القتال ودمويه اكثر وعدم احترام للادميه
اكثر لماذا لان بعض الاعين التي كانت
تراقب بعض الاعين التي كانت تراقب انسحبت
من المشهد اذن لا رقيب هنا وهذا يعيدنا
الى دارفور عندما دخل الجنجويد لمواجهه
القبائل ذات الاصول الزنجيه وكان الحديث
لاحقا عن محكمه لاهايل محاكمه مجرمي الحرب
اذا دعيني اقول في حال غياب الشاهد او
غياب من ناقل الحقيقه
ستزداد الامور استفعالا وظلاميه وسوداويه
للاسف السوداني يمر بمنعه خطير اذا لم
تتحرك
المجموعه الدوليه والمجموعه الاقليميه
والمجموعه الافريقيه والعربيه تحديدا
ويساهم في انقاذ السودان السودان على شفا
حرف على شفا جرفنهار
انقطع لو سمحت تعيدي اخر السؤال انقطع
الصوت عن الاعذار التي قدمت من قبل الشام
الاتحاد نعم فايز من قبل الاجسام الفاعله
سياسيا في الاتحاد في افريقيا
الايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي كان مفترض
ارسال مبعوثين الى السودان جرى التعذر بان
المطار غير امن هل تراه عذر امني مقبول
بالنسبه لمبعوثين بمثل هذا الظرف من
افريقيا
لا اعتقد ذلك وهذا عذر غير مقبول لا اود
ان استخدم توصيفا اخر كيف تم اجراء
الرعايه بعض الرعايه تم اجراهم بالطائرات
لم ترسل كافه الجماعات التي تم اجلاها الى
بورد سودان او الى اثيوبيا او الى الغضارف
مبدئيا ومن ثم الى اثيوبيا كيف هبطت هذه
الطائرات وكيف استطاعت الوصول وكيف
استطاعت اخلاء 75 امريكي كيف تم اخلاء
الجماعات البريطانيه حوالي 100 مئه من
الرعايه دعيني اقول لو كان هناك اصرارا
وجعل حياه الفرد في السودان تكافئ حياه
المسؤول الذي كان سياتي كان يمكن له
الوصول لكن الفرق الوحيد ان عمليات
الاجلاء جاءت تحت التهديد والترهيب وليس
تحت وليس تحت الرجاء والطلب يعني عندما
امريكا ارسلت الطائرات
الطائرات وهي تحمل العسل الغليظه هناك
القوات الامريكيه
وقسم منها موجود في جيبوتي كذلك بريطانيا
بينما الايجاد لا الايجاد هي كانت تتمنى
على الاخرين ان يضمنوا سلامه الوصول
الممثلين هناك يعني
ولكن ساعود اليك لوقفه وهنا ارحب بالسيد
عزمي عبد الرزاق الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
انضم الينا من
الخرطوم سيد عزمي هل ترى هناك امكانيه
لذهاب الى هدى حتى وان كانت يعني هدى
عليله كالعدن التي جرى خرقها في السابق
خاصه بعد
جلاء البعثات الدبلوماسيه هل الامر يعني
باتا ممكن
وبطبيعه الحال نحن الان في حاله ابتعدنا
لمده 72 ساعه ومع ذلك هنالك مناوشات
ومحاولات لاطلاق النار ولكن اعتقد بانه
الطرفين التزما بالهدنه لسبب واحد لانه
الطرف الثالث المعنى اللي نزلت الهدنه هي
البعثات الدبلوماسيه والسفراء والوزارات
الخارجيه كانت على تواصل مباشر مع الحكومه
مع الطرفين مع الجيش ومع الدعم السريع
وبالتالي مخاوف الطرفين بانه ما يحصل اي
عمليه بتاعت اعاقه
لاجلاء الاجلاء العالقين واجلاء السفراء
واجلاء البحثات الدبلوماسيه وبالتالي
التزام بالهدنه طوال هذا اليوم خصوصا في
المناطق التي تم فيها تمت في عمليه
الادلاع هي منطقه جنوب الخرطوم وكذلك
اعتقد بانه هنالك مناطق حدوديه ومنطقه بول
السوداني يعني ليست فيها اي عمليه
اشتباكات الاشتباكات كلها تدور في وسط
الخرطوم الان بدات تنحسب بشكل كبير جدا
الجيش يبدو بانه مسيطر تماما على الاوضاع
وخصوصا بعدين نجح في تدمير كله معسكرات
الدعم السريع ونجح بشكل كبير جدا في بسطه
الامن الان الاوضاع في كثير جدا من اطراف
العاصمه وحتى في اوساطها بدات تعود الهدوء
بدا يعود هنالك حاله حركه سيارات هنالك
بعض المتاجر والمخابز فتحت ابوابها
وبالتالي يبدو بانه هذه الهدنه التي سوف
تنتهي خلال هذا اليوم او صباح يوم القد
بانه سوف تستانف الاطراف الاخرى عمليه
القتال ولكن القتال الان ليست هنالك عمليه
اشتباك مباشر القوات المسلحه السودانيه
تقوم بتكتيك واضح جدا واستراتيجيه قائمه
على الارهاق وقايمه على العزل وحصار ودعم
السريع في مناطقها التي ذهبت الى الاحياء
والى العمارات السكنيه للاحتماء بها خوفا
من سلاح الطيران يشكل تهديد مباشر على تلك
القوات الان القوات الدعم السريع فقدت
الوقود وقود السيارات طيب اسمح لي ان ارحب
ايضا بضيفي السيد الجميل الفاضل الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي من الخرطوم سيد جميل
الفاضل
هل هناك امكانيه من وجهه نظرك
بالتواصل الى هدنه حقيقيه تمهد الطريق
باتجاه انهاء القتال والذهاب الى حوار
بوساطه ما
نعم
سيدي الجميل
سيد جميل تسمعني الان
نعم نعم
مع خروقات
الهدى الثلاثه وخاصه بان الهدنه الاخيره
هي كانت من اجل اجلاء الدبلوماسيون وبعثات
الاجنبيه الامر الذي سارع الطرفين
للتاكيد على الالتزام بها ومع ذلك كان
هناك خروقات ولكن هناك لا زالت نبره
انعدام من الثقه وانعدام الاراده ايضا
للوصول الى حل هل هناك امكانيه مع غياب
عامل الثقه وغياب الاراده من قبل الطرفين
في الذهاب حتى الى هدنه يجري تطبيقها على
الارض
الهدنه
نعم انا في تقدير الان كافه المؤشرات تدل
على ان الفجوه فجوه الصغر قد اتسعت لدرجه
كبيره كلا الطرفين كلا الجنرلين الان لا
يصيغان ببعضهما البعض بعد ان دخلنا الان
الاسبوع الثاني في تقدير ان اخلاء الخرطوم
من الرعايه الاجانب ايضا يعطي مؤشر
وقراءات تدل على ان التقديرات تذهب باتجاه
ان هذه المعارك ربما لا تنحسر قريبا
وبالتالي
امكانيه الجلوس
للوصول الى اي صيغه اتفاق بوقف العدائيات
او بوقف اطلاق النار او بالاعلان عنه هدنه
طويله المدى انا في تقديرها ان كل هذا
الان ابات بعيدا خاصه وان الفتره الاخيره
شهدت مزيد من كثافه النيران والمواجهات
واحتلال بعض المواقع واخلائها وحرب
اعلاميه كثيفه ايضا تدور من هذا الطلب
تصداق الطرف هذا يعني ان الرغبه في
الاستمرار في هذه المنازله والمواجهه لا
زالت هي سيده الموقف ولا ادري لو ان من
الانهاك او الضعف او الخبر قد اصاب
الاطراف ربما ربما يتم التفكير في طريقه
ما للوصول الى على الاقل وقت لاطلاق النار
الجهود الدولية
بان الطرفين
مع مثلا ما تحدث به ضيفنا سيد عزمي بان
الامور في الخرطوم باتت يعني تحت سيطره
الجيش هل توافق سيد عزمي مثل هذا الراي
سيد جميل حتى حتى الان على الشارع
تفضل
يوجد انتشار لقوات الدعم السريع ويوجد
انتشار للقوات الجيش وتبدا
عمليات الكرو والفر وهذا لا زال يتكرر حتى
في هذا اليوم
تقررت
القصف المدفعيه في حول محيط الوسط الخرطوم
وهناك معارك جرت
وهجمات بسلاح الجو في مناطق متفرقه من
العاصمه من ام درمان من غيرها في تقديرها
ان النيه في ان يصل هؤلاء الاطراف الى الى
انهاء هذه الحاله غير موجوده لا نستطيع ان
نقول ان بطبيعه المعارك نفسها باعتبار ان
المعارك الان ذهبت الى ان تصبح هي حرب
الشوارع وبالتالي طبيعه هذه المعارك تختلف
عن
الطريقه السيده عزمي لكي استفيد من الوقت
المتبقي السيد عزمي ما سيناريوهات اليوم
التالي حتى وان استتب الامر على سبيل
المثال مثلا او نفترض بانه كما تحدثت في
الخرطوم استتبى الوضع للجيش ما سيناريو
اليوم التالي في باقي الاماكن
وبطبيعه المعركه الان بانها بتدور داخل
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وتحديدا في
منطقه محيط القصر الرئاسي الذي تتمركز فيه
وتتموضع فيه قوات الدعم السريع منذ اليوم
الاول ولكن القوات المسلحه بطبيعتها هي
النواه الصليب التي تتكسر فيها كل محاولات
الهجوم الان محيط القياده خالي تمام من
قوات الدعم السريع كذلك المطار كذلك يعني
معظم المدن الرئيسيه تنتشر فيها القوات
المسلحه الشوارع الرئيسيه شارع المطار
شارع الستين حتى المدخل نحو ولايه الجزيره
جنوبا حتى عمليه الاجلاء القوات المسلحه
كانت على اشراف مباشره
لماذا لا يفتح ويجري الاجراء البعثات مثلا
كبير جدا في ضرب القوه الفاعله للدعم
السريع ويستطاع انه ينتهي من البنيه
التحتيه والقدرات العسكريه لغات الدعم
السريع وبالتالي هذه القوات العامه فاقده
للقياده هي مشتته في الاحياء ليست لديها
رؤيه واضحه في الاول كان هدفها هو عزل
قياده الجيش والاستيلاء على السلطه الان
هي تقاتل للحفاظ على الادل على موقف
تفاوضي عشان تدخل مساله التفاوض يعني بعد
وقف اطلاق النار ولكن على مستوى
الانتصارات العسكريه الجيش العالي يتمدد
المرحله المقبله هي مرحله الانتشار
والتمشيط ويبدو بانه لديه خطه وتكتيك الان
ويستخدم اسلحه على الاقل هي تمنحه
الافضليه وتمنحه التفوق اسرار المقبل هو
يبدو الان بانه قوات المسلحه هناك التفاف
شعبي حولها هنالك
صعوبه بالتواصل وانه لا يسمعني اشكرك سيد
عزمي اشكرك سيد عزمي عبد الرزاق الصح في
والمحلل السياسي من الخرطوم ايضا اشكر
ضيفي الجميل الفاضل الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي ايضا من الخرطوم واللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه من
عمان شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا على المشاركه
معنا في هذه الحلقه مما وراء الخبر اعزائي
المشاهدين شكرا لكم على المتابعه والتغطيه
مستمره والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]